I'M NOT SURE THIS IS GOING TO
HELP.
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS THE SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR WHO JOINS
"PRIMETIME" NOW.
SO, CHUCK IS NOW AMNESTY CHUCK.
I MEAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT SUSPICIOUS TIMING, SENATOR?
>> WELL, ALL I CAN SAY YOU ARE
ON TO SOMETHING HERE MY FRIEND.
YOU KNOW, OBAMA HAD 60 SENATORS
IN THE SENATE H A MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE AND NEVER EVEN BROUGHT
IMMIGRATION UP.
THIS IS AN EFFORT BY DEMOCRATS
TO TRY TO LABEL US AS
ANTI-HISPANIC, IT AIN'T GOING TO
WORK.
HERE IS WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN.
I HOPE KEVIN McCARTHY IS THE
SPEAKER SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
IF THE HOUSE DOESN'T SEND THE
SENATE A BORDER SECURITY BILL
FROM HELL, WE MADE A MISTAKE.
THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE ANY
DEAL ON IMMIGRATION UNTIL WE
SECURE THE BORDER.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF TIME A
BUNCH OF US GET KILLED BECAUSE
THE BORDER IS BROKEN AND
TERRORISM IS ON THE RISE.
SO HERE IS MY MESSAGE TO MY
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUE, THERE WILL
BE NO DEALS ON IMMIGRATION UNTIL
WE SECURE THE BORDER.
TO MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES IN
THE HOUSE, SEND US A BORDER
SECURITY BILL STRONG AS HELL AND
WE WILL MAKE THE DEMOCRATS VOTE
ON IT IN THE SENATE.
>> Jesse: WHY CAN'T CHUCK
SCHUMER JUST SAY IF WE'RE NOT
HAVING BABIES IN AMERICA LET'S
HAVE SOME MORE BABIES.
WHY DOES HE HAVE TO BLOW UP THE
BORDER AND INVITE THE ENTIRE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE INTO THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
>> THIS IS THE SAME GROUP OF
PEOPLE TAXPAYER FUNDED ABORTION
UP TO THE MOMENT OF BIRTH
TALKING ABOUT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PEOPLE.
SO IT MAKES NO SENSE.
IT'S ALL POLITICS.
BUT, LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON.
DECEMBER THE 6TH WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN ELECTION IN GEORGIA.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR HERSCHEL WALK
TORE COME TO THE SENATE.
HE WILL CANCEL OUT A LOT OF THIS
CRAZY STUFF.
HOW ABOUT THIS IDEA?
WE ARE GOING TO DISHARNG OVER
5,000 SOLDIERS FROM OUR MILITARY
BECAUSE THEY WON'T TAKE THE
COVID VACCINE.
WE HAVE HAD 4 MILLION PEOPLE
COME INTO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, UNVACCINATED.
THEY GET A FREE WEEKEND IN LAS
VEGAS.
HERSCHEL WALKER NEEDS TO COME TO
THE SENATE, LINDSEY GRAHAM.COM.
EVERY PENNY YOU GIVE ME, NOT
HALF OF IT, ALL OF IT GOES TO
HERSCHEL AND THE GEORGIA G.O.P.
LOOK AT THE POLICY OPPORTUNITY
WE HAVE.
WE SHOULD HAVE EVENT THE FLOOR
OF THE SENATE THAT WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE DO NOT GET
DISCHARGED WHO ARE WILLING TO
FIGHT FOR THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE
THEY REFUSE THE VACCINE.
WE HAVE GOT A DUMB COUNTRY.
WE ARE LETTING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS COME HERE
UNVACCINATED.
GOING TO FREE TRIPS ALL OVER
AMERICA AND WANT TO DISCHARGE A
WARRIOR.
WE SHOULD HAVE A BORDER SECURITY
BILL FROM HELL COMING OUT OF THE
HOUSE AND WE SHOULD DO ENERGY
DOMINANCE.
WE NEED THE SEAT, FOLKS.
LISTEN, WE WON THE HOUSE TODAY.
DECEMBER THE 6TH LET HERSCHEL
WIN.
LINDSEY GRAHAM.COM.
THE MONEY GOES TO THE GEORGIA
G.O.P. IT.
GOES TO HERSCHEL.
ONE LESS VOTE FOR THIS CRAZY
CRAP.
IF WE CAN WIN IN DECEMBER WE
WILL HAVE THE WIND TO OUR BACK.
>> Jesse: I CAN SEE THAT BUMPER
STICKER RIGHT NOW.
ONE LESS VOTE FOR THE CRAZY CRAP
TEAM HERSCHEL.